huh
well
made it this far
jack frederick
new member snazzy supporter thank you
very much for that and that can serve as
the uh inaugural me noting that the
thing that will guarantee
um that i read your comment and or
address your questions will be
if um
you submit a super chat or if you're
already a uh patreon supporter if you
put it in the
live stream discord channel um but i
will try and keep up with the chat
otherwise
but no guarantees otherwise plus if
super chats thank you to the heart from
me and my thank you so
hope everybody is feeling
all right
i am on day two of being 40.
that
it's weird
but it's not
upsetting
like
it feels like a number that a lot of
people freak out about
like i've sort of played up the idea
you know oh my god i'm turning 40. ah
i mean the reality is
i feel the same as i did two days ago
what's the big deal
ah
just talking about how great i look well
as you should
clearly
uh
how was my breakfast cake the breakfast
cake was delightful my mother made that
that's homemade cake
um
and it does actually work as a breakfast
it's dense
happy belated for you thank you
thank you for clarifying the disney
stuff so well that was oh that was such
a headache i i am really glad that
people have found it helpful though
happy belated birthday
happy your day ooh
40th is next year well join me
molly join me in
uh
in the milf phase of life
um
[Music]
i barely remember my 40s i
i'm sure you remember some things
garowen pretty sure that's alcohol i
don't know what you're talking about
and
you can't prove that to be true
a couple more years you'll be the answer
to the ultimate question of life the
universe and everything thank you so
much for getting that right
i try not to be an [ __ ] about it but
like it does really rub me the wrong way
when people go oh 42 is the meaning of
light i'm like it's not the meaning it's
the answer to the great question which
we don't actually know what it is but
it's not the meaning so thank you for
getting that right
i appreciate that greatly
uh
people making a fuss about turning 30 40
50 or whatever is a scam i mean it is a
scam but like
it is also like a thing it does kind of
worm its way into your head if you let
it
uh
so you know
i just turned 30
so happy new decade to both of us yes
jesse turns 30 this year
that was frustrating to realize we will
never be in the same decade of life at
the same time
ah
so um i did get sent a number of things
uh some off my wish list some things not
um
which i am going to be uh
showing off and like
sort of opening like i did check
everything that came in
um
uh
wow
uh either because i needed to be sure
that it was cleared off the wish list
once i received it and then the other
reason was i have in the past received
requests from people like in notes
included that they actually didn't want
things uh opened on air so i don't i
don't do that blindly anymore
but i will be talking a little bit about
some of the stuff that was sent my way
because there were some very lovely
things from some very lovely people all
greatly appreciated
uh
you're just as hot as you were two days
ago also
[Laughter]
thank you jay beals
i appreciate that
actually childhood is overrated too
i
i mean child well some people don't have
good childhoods i would say childhood is
something that's hard to appreciate
while you're in it
even if you have a good one
oh john vinyls thank you so much
thoughts on balto we're back a dinosaur
story and or the american tale series
okay i've never seen we're back so toss
that one out
i have seen the first and i think the
third balto movie
they were better than i expected them to
be they were decent uh they didn't stick
too much in my head though i saw them
when i was older like in my 30s
i can now say in my 30s and that is a
distinctly passed period of time gotta
use to that uh as for an american tale
um i
grew up on the original i i liked at the
time fivel goes west
um but i
i find that and this is something that
actually happens a little bit with all
dogs go to heaven as well
with um
with a character like
oh god what's her name
anne-marie
uh that the cutesyness of don bluth
sometimes grates on me it's like a
little too saccharine um and that goes
on a little bit in american tale uh with
fivel's characterization in particular
that having been said like i i like don
bluth's visual style very much and i
definitely appreciate what he's going
for with those movies
um yeah i
i like them i don't love them that's
sort of where i am on that
captain omni thank you for the super
chat
happy spirit journey formation
anniversary ooh
i like that bonus points if you get the
reference
uh sadly not but i like it anyways
most times are hard to appreciate until
after they're gone yeah
don't it always seem to go
that you don't know what you got till
it's gone
who do i want to play the next doctor
joe martin
i'm gonna stand by that until i'm told
it's somebody else
not a single gray hair on you oh that's
a lie
that's a freaking lie i don't know if
you folks realize how much gray i have i
don't know how well it shows up under
the shooting lights you see me under
natural light you see me in sunlight
there is so much gray
oh it's crazy i've got like a it's
like i have to run my fingers through it
to get it to show up because it's kind
of covered most of the time but there's
like a whole streak of gray up in here
it's
it's not minor it's not subtle it's
it's increasingly prominent
i also kind of like it like i've
embraced it at this point but like oh no
i i i am not i am not uh free of grays
so
if you think i am it just means that the
the lighting setup is very generous to
me that's all that that means
oh captain omni thank you very much
uh the beatles the monkeys or the
rolling stones stones
easily the stones now granted if you're
taking like the latter day careers of
the stones it gets a little
but if
i basically consider their
heyday
of the 60s into the 70s to be so good i
kind of don't care whether or not they
suck later on
i prefer the stones
uh
when did when did i first notice greyer
white here uh
at 29
[Laughter]
that's when i started noticing like
single individual strands
um
but it's it's it's
spread
since then
there's a german burlesque performer
famous for her flowing gray locks gray
can be very hot the thing is though you
actually look at uh i mean again you
can't really see them under this light
but you look at my grays i've kind of
skipped gray they've gone right to white
so i'm not i don't really have the oh
you're starting to gray it's like no
individual strands have just given up
[Laughter]
giving given the hugh grant rumors going
around i'd be up for david's wasting
several regenerations in the 60th and
getting all
fatal death doctors and i really don't
want them to do that like it only worked
in a humorous context and i'm sorry it's
wasteful
in anything other than a joke context
it's wasteful of a concept it's wasteful
of people's time it's ways full of
people's hopes when they see somebody
playing the doctor who they would like
to keep playing the doctor but won't
ah
very seem to like my gray hair well
enough well
you look lovely with your hair carolyn i
did like your hair i do like your hair
present tense
uh
oh
captain omni one more time thank you so
much my cousin went full steve martin
hair at 19. i kid you not i had a friend
in high school
who went completely silver
i think she was 23.
i remember i saw her and i ass i had
assumed it was something she did on
purpose and i was like i like your hair
she was like thanks i just lost all my
color about a year ago i was like oh
crap and i felt bad because even though
i had complimented it
um like i didn't know if i'd touched a
point that she was sensitive about or
not so yeah that happens it's also one
of the reasons like it's been really
hard for me to
like
pin down
um
steve martin's age because he wouldn't
he went gray so dang young
white strands in your hair so you're
rogue it's not that prominent a streak
yet maybe we'll get there
excuse me
do i like the song sweet child of mine
by guns and roses it's all right
80s hair metal isn't really my genre but
now that's a decent song
i suppose we'll start talking gifts by
starting with
this
which was gifted to me by
one of my burlesque friends
at a gathering
on saturday
my friend libby gave me this
um and i'm actually wearing
uh some i don't know if you can see them
these little blue dot earrings on either
side friend ginge gave me those
um oh and apologies up front
if anybody who sent me a something
that i don't mention because i tried to
remember everything that came and i
tried to like keep it all together but
something in my gut is telling me i've
lost track of something that there was
something that was sent to me early in
the month
off the wish list that i that i
don't remember what it is or where it
went i don't know if that's true but i
have a gut feeling it is so if that ends
up being true and i miss something and
don't thank somebody i'm sorry i
definitely got it
but my mind has drawn a blank
because i have adhd and i'm old so there
you go
oh captain omni again big spender
pink floyd jethrotul or king crimson
well i don't know king crimson
oh
i
think um
here okay so here's the thing
the things
of pink floyd's that i like
i like about as much as the things from
death row jethro tell that i like
however there's more stuff from pink
floyd that i like so i think i'll have
to go to pink floyd on that
that that's that wasn't super easy
though all right let's try this
that's very pleasant
i shall have to thank libby well the
other thing libby gave me was a jar of
pickles which is already empty and gone
uh that happened
yesterday
that was dead so
uh
what is my favorite edition of jun of
dungeons and dragons i haven't played
all that many and i haven't played them
in enough detail to
know all the differences so i'm actually
not a good resource on that i like at
this point i've spent the most time
playing 5e and i enjoy it so that works
for me
question has there been something that
you knew would be bad or not great just
from the look and when it uh comes out
you're like
someone pick up the phone because i
freaking called it
yeah that's that's definitely
happened
i'm trying to think of a good
example
though
because there have definitely been cases
where like i've gone
like looked at a trailer and gone this
trailer
looks bad and been told oh you can't you
can't be all like down on that and like
it's just a trailer and then it comes
out and it is
it is bad it is in fact very bad
um i'm having a hard time
uh
making a call on that
as to like a good specific example but i
it's definitely happened oh clay leach
thank you very much happy belated
birthday i'm only 22 i have a long way
to go well hopefully we all have a long
way to go that's that's the hope what
are my thoughts on pink floyd's the wall
see i bet you already know that that
album used to be on a bit of a loop when
i was in high school do i listen to rap
not really i never really got into it i
appreciate it and i get i understand on
an intellectual level its appeal it just
doesn't really appeal to me
didn't even make it home the pickles no
well no technically they did it was
about a third of the jar left by the
time i got home and then i just ate them
i i like i was unpacking from getting
back home
i took the jar out it didn't even make
the fridge i just finished them
[Laughter]
uh
happy birthday boxing day
thank you ben
uh
they do say life begins at 40. yeah you
know who says that
people over 40.
my i'm not saying they're necessarily
wrong i'm just saying they kind of have
a vested interest in that mentality
if i see much of critical role i've
actually not seen or heard any of
critical role other than the theme music
theme music's great i love it but no i
haven't got around to that
one of many things i have yet to get to
oh you were talking about the movie the
wall
um i like it it's weird it's dark i
gotta be in a certain mood if i'm gonna
get through it but
it's it's good and again something i've
watched a bit in high school
uh we all have a long way to go that's
not my well when i say we all i i kind
of mean like we all
round about these parts not like we all
planet planet-wide
i'll leave it at that
um
oh captain omni thank you very much
my girlfriend is starting to get into
burlesque and she compared to my career
in d pro wrestling oh i would say
there's tons of comparisons to be made
there yes
yes
well i agree in the theatrical aspects
would you say that's 100 accurate i know
nothing of it 100 accurate well no it's
not a complete one to one but like you
have to develop a persona come up with a
stage name figure out how you want to
interact with audience elaborate
costumes choreographed moves no there's
a lot of parallels
yeah
no it's i i think that's super valid
that comparison i dig it i like it
uh
when i was 13 and saw a kick-ass 2
trailer i knew the second that trailer
started that movie was going to suck
i've never bothered to watch kick-ass 2.
oh i should start talking about some of
the stuff i got i don't know how well
this will show up because i know i've
got i've got the autofocus uh off so i
can't like pull this so close to the
camera that you'll actually be able to
see it properly because it won't focus
but
i got these were off my wish list these
little earrings with squirrels
on them
because uh because i have a squirrel
brain
so those were one thing
that i was sent
ah
grab another thing down here
happy birthday vera i'm of the opinion
that uh given more time or a better
script george clooney could have been a
good batman
same brandon routh a good superman
um
yeah potentially
you know that i think in both cases the
problems with their movies weren't them
i think that's very much the case in
both
uh situations there
this one oh yes this okay so this is the
one from gozer
uh
wrestling is butch burlesque confirmed
yes absolutely confirmed
um
i am looking forward to this and i did
open this earlier but this is um
this is this is an earring it's got a
it's got a dangle piece and since i've
got the multiple piercings now on this
side
um that's something i can actually
make use of the with the connector i'm
looking forward to that
thank you gozer
oh captain omni thank you very much as a
follow-up to the last one my current
wrestling gimmick is disco danger aka
disco sue puts the hurt on you
[Laughter]
oh
disco stew
oh what a
insane character i remember when the
character was first introduced and it
was a one-off gag
um
my cat can never catch a squirrel she
thinks she can though well many of them
do
uh
myself and a few friends are watching
batman and robin for our bad movie night
on saturday solid pick am i familiar
with the trainspotting films i am i've
only seen the first one though and not
in a long time probably been over 20
years since i've seen that mr l thank
you very much for the super chat my
friend happy first anniversary of your
39th birthday
yeah that's one way to obfuscate it
isn't it
i am turning i am turning
25
for the 16th time
ah chris mcgovern thank you very much
happy four oh vera even with grayish
hairs i would love to have some of your
hair where mine is a bit thin in the
back growing it long though
uh i like i i'm certainly grateful for
the hair i have gray or not
uh
there's no question about that
so um
some of the oh ham let me show this so
this
sweater liz got me this
um this is another design from
hi-ho silver works
um so it's you know sort of goth and
somewhat witchy which is very much their
aesthetic and
love their stuff
um what was this oh
i did see this but i i didn't take it
out of the bag to like get a proper
sense of it
oh
did i did i miss oh did i miss something
where i should have
said thanks ah
oh hey crispy pro it is good to see you
thank you
i missed you coming in because i'm very
self-absorbed like that
oh that oh that's gonna be fun
so it's
oh and it's it's lace up in the back um
so that's kind of uh that needs to be
ironed but that
oh that's got potential oh that'll
that'll be fun
thank you very much for whoever sent
that a lot of these didn't come with
notes although i know it's in many cases
because it's from amazon and not there
is the gift option with everything
um
captain omni once more thank you
uh if you got into pro wrestling
what would you make your gimmick and
persona would you incorporate some of
your blessed persona in it i have
no idea
um
i mean my natural inclination
would be to go
dominatrix-esque which i think lends
itself towards being a heel
um other than that i'm not sure i'm
prepared to
to figure out too much more happy uterus
escape anniversary
but i i feel like that's my go-to
thoughts
uh something i can recommend if you're
sick of dark and emo batman batman brave
and the bold yes i've had that
recommended to me by a few people um
i've seen
like a couple of episodes
am i gonna watch the new west side story
i was never planning to
like i just
i don't care
uh vera that's why i keep track of
things yes thank you so much
thank you so much carowind i really mean
that
uh oh meg said hi by the way she wanted
me to tell you that
uh happy birthday lady vera thank you
homebody much appreciated
frequent viewer of jessie gender tuning
in happy birthday oh thank you olivia
nice to see you here
so
um
one of the things i was sent
that uh
was off a wish list it was very
specifically off of the
uh vera wilde as opposed to council of
geeks wish list
um
so i can't
i i
maybe i could i i don't want i can't
show it on
stream because i don't want to risk
having the playback flagged as 18 plus
um but that that that was that was very
thoughtful
so
maybe maybe somewhere else i'll i'll
talk about what was sent off off of that
hmm um so this one ah this one came from
aaron o'connell there was a note with
this one
and i i have been i've been meaning to
see this for a while
batman versus the teenage mutant ninja
turtles
uh yes
yes please just on principle uh yes
oh
god the turtles i was so into them when
i was young
uh
how would how would i approach playing
the doctor if i was cast i
have no idea
um
i think
like the the idea that's kind of
stuck in my head when i've thought about
that is
um
hyper-focused
and in a way that cuts both ways
uh in a way that
um
like can really zero in on the problem
in a crisis but might also mean
they're failing to notice
that
um
you know that some that their companions
are in danger or that their own life
might be in danger
um
and that's sort of like a ground
level sort of to sort of start from
uh do i think i'd play a better doctor
or master well i'd rather play the
doctor i think master would be fun
turtle power yes right
uh say what all four of the turtles do
as mentioned in the original theme from
memory leonardo leads donatello does
machines raphael is cool but rude
michelangelo is a party dude
captain omni thank you once more for the
super chat i went disco for the sole
reason of despite being a metal head and
classic rock fan i always had a major
soft spot for disco as a guilty pleasure
there's nothing wrong with disco
like it had a bad rap for a while but
like
it was it was over saturated for sure
but there's nothing inherently wrong
with disco
my wrestling character is traditional
but my character like myself openly pan
has a little bearing on my character
because i hate all the lgbt wrestlers
being a heel and creepy oh
fair point
fair point
uh
have i watched any of the batman 2004
animated series um somebody is uh
talking about possibly commissioning me
for some of that
so
uh i've watched a little that might
happen soon i don't know yet we'll see
um have i seen any of the modern turtle
properties i really haven't
like i the thing is i know which
versions of the turtles i love
and
i'm not so in love with the concept that
i need to see every new iteration if
that makes sense
not that i'm like oh not my turtles i'm
sure they're fine just i don't know i'm
not so invested in that i feel the need
to
um uh i feel the need to
what was i gonna say i feel they need to
like
take in every alternate version
strum dynasty thank you very much would
you consider reading reading an audio
book on commission so
okay i gotta parse your question there
because
if you're asking if i would consider
listening to an audiobook as a
commission yes i mean truth be told i
frequently use audiobooks to supplement
my reading of physical works whenever i
commissioned for books because
finding time to actually sit down and
read is frequently difficult for me both
between my schedule and just with how my
brain works
um but if you're asking me to like
narrate an audio book that wouldn't be a
patreon commission that would be
we'd have to negotiate an actual
contract for me to do that as as work
um
but i'm not sure that's what you meant
it's just my brain realized that
that was a possible reading
um oh i meant recording to clarify oh
okay so yeah if you're asking
if i would make myself
available as a
as a narrator for an audiobook
yeah
yeah uh that that is uh priced that
would have that would have to be uh
determined and negotiated and it would
depend on length
uh to
a certain degree but
um
i also
like
i'm not gonna like say it publicly on
stream but like i could i know ballpark
what it would probably run because i
know what i had to pay to hire a
narrator for my audiobook so which i
need to get back to editing
[Music]
one of my material regrets is losing my
original tmnt comics over the course of
my travels and life oh that is a shame
i love the original turtles
like they're dumb
but i love them
i i love the original eastman and laird
would i ever cosplay as regina george
from mean girls no it's a boring cosplay
there's nothing particularly interesting
about any of her looks not to me at any
rate so no absolutely not
i've ever seen todd todd's video about
katy perry's witness album yes i did i
keep up with todd's stuff
uh he mentions the front cover possibly
being inspired by the neon demon yeah i
saw that i was hoping he would
off-handedly say that the neon demon
sucks uh he didn't
that's fine
i seem to be
one of the
depressingly small number of people
willing to bang that drum of how bad the
neon demon
freaking
sucks
it's sucks
is there a remake or a movie or tv show
that you think is better than the
original oh yeah there's definitely some
out there um
if you're asking me to come up out on my
head i'm probably not gonna pull that
together
but now they're they're definitely out
there
um can you give me examples of villains
and tv shows that get better after they
are defeated rather early on rather than
suck oh okay so what you're kind of
talking about
is
just sort of the the issue of villains
who who get defeated but like stick
around and how that tends to
um
really hamper their effectiveness as
villains
uh so again
i probably could
i'm not coming up with any off the very
top of my head unfortunately
uh
which means that
it puts me in a situation where i i
don't
doubt
that
i i could come up with some i just i'm
not gonna sit here and struggle in front
of camera trying to think of it because
that's not interesting streaming
uh
i never heard of neon demon until that
video yeah you don't need to hear about
the neon demon
and the neon demon also killed any uh
interest i've ever had in ever seeing
anything by nicholas winding refin the
the writer director on that because once
i saw how far up its own ass that movie
was i'm like i don't want to ever see
anything by this director
ew angus hello
don't know why that turned into mrs
doubtfire hello
he left upon me that i'm melting like a
snow cone in phoenix
following your no time to die catch up
uh how long before people catch to the
fact its main villain makes no sense and
it renders the rubbish specter even more
pointless feels like uh we're dealing
with sunk investment now
i like
the only thing that makes any sense to
me is why people were kinder to
no time to die than to spectre is
because it was craig's last outing and
he was pretty decent in it so i feel
like people
wanted to like that more they wanted it
to be good i think some people maybe
even needed it to be good
it's not though
it's really not
and it
doesn't make sense
oh um
venga boys are back in town
thank you very much for the super chat
that was just fun to say out loud
uh scarecrow and batman begins was that
kind of villain for me he kept showing
up in the sequels and being beaten
almost immediately
yeah he was a little bit
um i
i didn't think his appearance made a
heck of a lot of sense in uh dark knight
rises i did think it made sense in the
dark knight
um
oh
uh tara staller thank you very much
happy birthday vera it's scary how much
we have in common with our birthdays
being close and the same age and the
grays i i had slightly less but may have
changed since i started dying it like
since six months ago
uh
it's it's
it's a process
the uh the loss of color
but chemicals can put it back
um
uh oh
michael anderson doyle thank you very
much all hail queen nathaniel three
months no regrets thank you so much for
keeping up with the membership i greatly
appreciate that do i like milkshakes
heck yes i like milkshakes absolutely
uh
i'm watching the james bond movies in
order i've only watched dr no i'm sorry
i wouldn't recommend doing that
i really really wouldn't
but best of luck to you
oop jon vinyls thank you so much uh
random rant i hate the argument of it's
a space wizard movie for kids it doesn't
need to make sense or have complex
themes uh what do
like
here's my general uh comeback to anyone
who says
that
it doesn't need to be
smart
or it doesn't it doesn't matter if it
has themes
because it's for kids or because it's a
blockbuster because it's mainstream
entertainment you know what
when there is a kids movie that has
those things like a good pixar movie or
that there is a blockbuster with more on
its mind than just fireworks
i never hear anyone say man i wish this
was dumber i wish this had fewer themes
nobody says that they only say it as an
excuse to defend something that is
lacking in an area that there's no
reason for it to be lacking in
yeah yeah like
yeah that drives me crazy
um
oh captain omni one more thank you if
you had your choice of toy man metallo
or brainiac and a superman reboot which
would you do also red trunks or no uh i
would
they need to at least come up with a
decent visual replacement for the red
trunks because without them the solid
blue top to bottom like you need the red
to break it up
you you really do they got to do
something if not the trunks which is the
traditional way to do it something man
you got to break up that blue
as far as those villains i would go for
brainiac and i part of the reason is i
think brainiac is all-purpose i think
brainiac has been around long enough
since things like
um you know the silver age where he was
a goofier villain
because everything was goofy back in the
day so he could work for a lighter
superman or if you want to go dark with
him you basically treat him like a like
a one-man board collective and you can
go techno horror with him if you're
going darker i think he's very malleable
that way
what villain or villains would you like
to see in the next batman movie uh not
the joker
give the dude a break
um beyond that
poison ivy
we are well overdue to get another crack
at poison ivy in a movie
happy birthday by the way thank you
dharma i appreciate that
i just binged all the rockies last year
for the first time whoa
that's a project i haven't seen i've
only seen
the first
the last
and the first creed
so i've seen i've seen bits and pieces
of the of others but i've only seen
three rocky movies well two rocky movies
and a spin-off
supreme omega thank you very much for
the super chat happy 40th question as
you get older how does your taste and
attitudes towards pop media like film tv
comics etc change especially the stuff
you grew up with
it actually doesn't that much
like
i will
i will come to a
better understanding
intellectually
of these things like i will be able to
better articulate what does or doesn't
work or i'll be able to recognize with a
more uh highly tuned critical lens
something and something i have deep
nostalgia for that it just doesn't work
or it has deep fundamental flaws
that does very little to change my
own inherent internal gut visceral
love of things or hatred of things
it's pretty rare for me to turn around
on something that
i hated or to start deeply disliking
something that i used to love
things might
soften in one direction or another but
not
completely
turn all the way around like something
that maybe i really didn't like i'll see
again as an adult and go okay there's
more merit to this than i thought there
was or something i watched out as a kid
and loved and watches them don't go okay
this isn't as good as my brain may it
had me remembering it but i'll still
ultimately land in the same general this
is good and i like it or this is bad and
i don't i just might soften on the
extremes in that
is is kind of the way it usually goes
i think eine taylor draw would be great
for poison ivy for matt reeves as batman
ah that could work that could work
clay face is a villain
they've never had the batman movies he's
one villain i'd love to see the movies
tackle well the reason we haven't had
clay fake wow reason's twofold clayface
as a villain could have fit in burton or
honestly even in schumacher the problem
was the technology wasn't really there
to do him justice as far as special
effects go
and the problem since then
is all of the batman movies since have
been too grounded in reality and
clayface is a very fantastical villain
he's a mud monster who shapeshifts
i would like to see him too but they
have to back off the realism to get him
to work i'd say you'd be more likely to
see him in something like the suicide
squad which is willing to go that kind
of ridiculous
cara watson thank you happy birthday
vera currently swimming in lesson plans
and panicking that my inspection might
be this week on my first week hope your
day is going better than mine my day is
going quite well i hope yours improves
um venga boys are back in town favorite
classic who companion exit teagan was
mine i miss you but my mental health is
suffering i'm gone yeah team was
team was real good
like
uh susan was good too but that was more
good for the doctor than like her exit
being good that was more like the
doctor's reaction to her exit was really
good
um i i might
i think i might be with you on that i
might i might be with you there for
teagan
oh tara staller never any story legend
or labyrinth
[Music]
okay
never ending stories going at the bottom
still good still like it but it's not
it's not at the same level
and so now you've got me
my brain competing
between tim curry as darkness
oh
daddy um
and david bowie is jareth
okay the thing is i can't decide between
them so i have to set them aside and go
by everything else in the movie going by
everything else in the movie that isn't
the villains because i can't pick
between them
then it goes to labyrinth because i like
more of the other stuff that's in there
than with legend i do still like a lot
of legend but honestly
if it wasn't for tim curry i might not
care about that movie
labyrinth i think i wouldn't love it the
same without david bowie but i probably
still care about it so i think i gotta
give it to labyrinth
uh have i seen the netflix show called
human resources nope i have seen that it
exists i have seen
uh like parts of trailers didn't look
that uh interesting or appealing to me
oh
what was in here
huh
all right i don't know what i did with
that
i have to check around
had a had a package
don't know
oh this might this might have been the
package
for the
um
for the squirrel earrings
i hope so otherwise something's floating
around in here and i don't know where um
so
what else oh uh i mentioned uh something
that came off the vera wildt okay so
there's one other thing that
i kind of debated
uh whether or not
i was um going to actually
uh give thanks for this item
because this this was
this was something that was on the wish
list but it was on the wish list more as
a placeholder for me to keep track of
and more of a thing that i thought i
might get for myself not with the
expectation that anyone would ever
actually buy it for me off the wish list
um
and again i i kind of i kind of debated
giving thanks for this because part of
me was like
this is actually kind of extravagant and
i don't like
the idea that other people might be left
feeling that their gifts whether it be
little you know things that i've shown
littler things or even just the the
super chats like isn't enough and they
should have done
what i'm about to show you but
then i realized like there was no note
with this one so i have no way of
confirming that i received it and giving
my thanks without doing so here so let
me just note
i don't think i'm going to be keeping
anything of this level of extravagance
on
the wish list going forward just because
it like
i love it and i'm just really glad to
have it but like it felt weird to get in
a way um
but somebody
sent me an ipad
so i have an ipad now
which i've never had before
um
have already figured out some
interesting ways to put it to use uh
given that i am i am partial to putting
like say um
youtube uh longer youtube videos on in
the background while doing stuff this
now enables me to do that
while also doing stuff on my phone
because i i don't have to be in the app
on this
um
so there's there's things like that and
it's uh
i've had some use for it for tick-tock
purposes and some other things but yeah
that was uh
that was that was something so thank you
whoever sent me that
i appreciate it oh got some more super
chats that came in angus thank you again
so much
forgot to actually say happy birthday
and which studio ghibli films have you
watched i assume lily spirit away
mononoke and your favorites okay i've
seen well i've seen all of miyazaki's
movies
um
so those i've all seen
i've seen some of the non-miyazaki
ghibli movies like i've seen um
a grave of the fireflies i've seen
cigarette world of variety
um
my single favorite is ghost of total i'm
sorry ghost jesus my neighbor my
neighbor totoro i'm like my my brain was
mashing several things together there my
neighbor totoro and my nostalgic
favorite is princess mononoke
because that was the first
miyazaki movie i saw
so i love those a lot
captain omni thank you very much the
time has come the walrus said to talk of
other things of shoes and ships and
sealing wax and cabbages and kings and
why the sea is boiling hot
and where the pigs have
[Music]
wings yeah that should do
yes discord thank you
very much carowen i will get right to
that um
what's my second favorite fourth doctor
story after city of death
um
pirate
planet so hang on i gotta jump on over
to
the
uh discord real quick
see what's in there
uh
so first was there a time change in the
u.s yes because we haven't gotten rid of
daylight savings yet apparently there's
like a bill in congress that they might
actually get rid of it
which would be amazing
that i'd love that but yet
there was a time change
um question overall how
how have you been enjoying babylon 5 so
far um i'm only a couple of episodes in
so it's early to tell i will say that
like the thing that i'm
that i like the most about it is what
jesse's telling me is the strongest
aspect which is the political
machinations i find really interesting
uh some other elements of it are a
little like
[Music]
but um
but i i'm enjoying it so far
uh what else have i got 35 hurt me more
than 40 did don't know why
i believe that hope it's going good for
you it is it's going quite well so far
trams fend people trans femme people and
pickles such a thing like the thing like
i was
i was a pickle addict even before
i was on sperno so
long running for me squirrel brain for
the win yes
heck yes can't wait to hear
what you can't show on screen yeah
yeah
i'll probably uh i'll probably mention
it in um
[Music]
in the council of geeks discord in the
uh nsfw
uh channel
um every time i hear someone say they're
40 i just picture mike gundy screaming
in my head guess i chose how much sports
nut i am i don't know who my gundy is
i will uh i'll take your word for that
uh also once again happy birthday 40 is
a nice number very fun to say 40
40. i'm gonna go on record in saying if
you want to watch the american song
contest i wasn't planning to
but here's some advice please don't such
a bastardization of something european
on the same level of doctor who 1996
movie
yeah i mean that's the impression i got
it's basically american eurovision which
why
uh birthday or yule cards funny or
heartfelt i tend to prefer
funny um i don't mind
okay
if i'm opening it in the presence of
whoever gave it to me i would much
prefer funny if the person who gave it
to me is not going to be present for my
opening of it heartfelt is fine i just
feel really awkward reading something
super heartfelt with the person sitting
right there it just feels weird to me
uh no pickles for me worked at a pickle
factory for a summer came home smelling
like brine oh
it's a good thing you didn't know me i
would have jumped all over you
so let me just check one other thing
here real quick
okay
oh one last thing uh mike gundy uh is
really only famous for being a coach who
screamed
that he's a 40 year old man when the
media attacked one of his players
okay
okay then
all right i'm back in the chat now
but i like the 1996 movie there are
things i like about the 1996 movie but
like it is a it is very much an
americanization of a british thing
now
anyone who's who watches me on tick tock
has seen me down a significant amount of
pickle brine
no regrets
mark rylance's character and don't look
up uh was a better bond villain than
sapping was
don't remind me of that movie
what does it mean when a grown man plays
with his toys
it
means he sells a sense of fun
that's probably a good thing
uh am i aware of a person called lumi
roo they're a non-binary twitch streamer
i got them to watch your video about
disney and they don't say gay bill on
stream i am not familiar with them i
will look into that
do i like the song black dog by led
zeppelin if i know that one i don't know
what off it's on my head i probably down
as much maple syrup oh maple syrup's
good stuff too
the bill is to make daylight savings
time permanent
okay but
like you say permanent but like to lock
in that as the time like we don't switch
anymore it's the same ultimate
thing it's it's the same
outcome
don't confuse me when i'm hydrating
which incarnation of the doctor would be
in a story where they saved the porn
industry from aliens
the right answer is 12 browser history
yeah no i buy that 12 strikes me as more
sex positive in general i think he would
um
you know what
i think six might too
do i prefer sneakers heels or boots um
slippers
uh do i like the movie ponyo i do
it's a weird one that one but i do enjoy
it
did i ever watch regular show nope
i like i i
have been in the room when it's on
that's about all i've got
uh if the bill passes
new england will be on atlantic time
okay
i just want time to stop jumping back
and forth i don't really care which one
we lock in on just stick to one and
leave it there
greatest experience at a con i don't
know if i could name you great because
like
what's great about cons is a collective
thing and it's usually the
just the
culmination of the all the people you
meet all the people you see maybe some
who you knew online before you met them
and things like that
but
uh the thing that
like blew my mind
at a con uh was that
um
at this past gallifrey one
jason hey gallery who is the co-founder
and the managing director at big finish
spotted me recognized me
told me that he really liked
my videos and he watches my channel
that still blows my mind
there is some irony in you of all people
objecting to switching look
don't mess with my internal clock
that's all i'm saying i look
all kinds of switching all kinds of
switching i can get on board with be in
favor of but don't mess with my sleep
schedule
don't do that
ah
i think we are one bad middle-earth
thing away from fans going toxic and
saying the lord of the rings trilogy
wasn't
uh that good anyway just to be
contrarians i mean
some folks will just because
they're like that
like some people are just like that
whatever
um
but yeah i think i'm gonna i'm gonna
wrap it up soon
uh it's almost uh partly because it's
almost eight o'clock but also um
i've been hydrating and i need
i need a bio break
hamilton or six i don't know
they're very different
finally got around to watching gravity
falls favorite episode i've seen so far
is the rumble mix skirmish one oh rumble
mcskirmish
god that show's
wonderfully weird
what do i think of bridgeton i think
nothing i haven't seen it
uh have i seen sean's latest video uh
the one on harry potter i've seen that
it's up i haven't uh i haven't had the
spoons to deal with it
um i'm just not in the mood
to either discuss or hear anyone else
discuss those books and like i
understand that it's a largely critical
view of them i'm not saying he shouldn't
have done it or anything i'm just saying
i am not
i just don't wanna
i just don't wanna
that's
that's where i'm at at this point
if the planet was being invaded by
aliens which doctrine companion would
you pick to save the earth seven and ace
i feel like they they had the most
coherent dynamic
they would outsmart them or blow them up
uh
have i ever been in the room where it
happens well it depends on uh what it is
doesn't it
uh
he really rips them to shreds that's the
impression i had but like can i be
honest
part of the reason why i haven't watched
um
those videos
or videos like that
is because
as much as i
cannot ever get
uh pure
happiness or joy or anything that
isn't grievously tainted out of harry
potter anymore or ever again
those books still mattered to me
those movies still mattered to me
the connections i made with other people
geeking out over the fandom of those
things still mattered to me
and while there are
now and have always been
very valid criticisms to be made about
them
i'm not
loving
the general trend in certain uh aspects
of fandom or geekdom or leftist
talking points that have basically
decided well they were always crap and
here's why because
that feels like it's
oversimplifying in the opposite
direction of the people who ins who try
to defend jk rowling largely because
they love harry potter
you know it's it's it's just the
opposite side of this of the coin that
the idea that
good people good art is made by good
people and if they're a bad person then
their art must also be bad again this is
not to
waylay any of um sean's criticisms i'm
sure he makes very valid ones there's
plenty of very valid criticisms to be
made about harry potter
no doubt i'm not gonna defend the
friggin things
but
there's something that strikes me as
diverting and
being unwilling to contest
with the complexity of the situation in
your own feeling about it when somebody
goes from well jk rowling's a bad person
oh but i really like harry potter well
no harry potter was never any good it
just feels reductive
as a
as an angle to take things from and he
doesn't necessarily do that i don't know
if he does i haven't seen it but like i
know that it's highly negative towards
the work and i'm not in the mood
i'm just not
uh when lumiere watch your video she
said you you reminded them of jesse
because of how
generous you are even to people who
don't deserve it oh
i do take that as a compliment like i i
try
i try and give people
enough
benefit of the doubt that they can start
to get better i don't presume anyone
will get better but i try and give the
most generous interpretation of things
that i can or at least
mention the most generous interpretation
things of things that i can even if it's
not the one i'm inclined to believe
because
i would like those things to turn out to
be true
they frequently aren't but there we go
all right last super chat and then i
gotta wrap it up erin thank you so much
happy birthday and enjoy the movie oh i
will lots of birthdays around here
brother today me on saturday friend next
week well happy birthday
to all of you
i hope you have a good one on saturday
boy you really did sort of all crammed
together
um
but thank you
so much
for
joining me for this
i
getting older is easier when you can do
it in good company and i am very
fortunate to have an amazing partner
to age with
um to still be uh good friends with my
kid's mother get to age with her
although she denies aging she still
claims to be 25 and our kids getting to
an age that that's starting to get
creepy but
you know my i have friends that it feels
good to be aging with and
you folks
when you're around getting older doesn't
seem like that big a deal cause
i'm doing it in the presence
of good people
so
thank you
and thank you carolyn for the reminder
twitch tomorrow i'm done
with final fantasy vii remake i didn't
finish it i won't
i
could not deal with it anymore
um i'll be tearing into that at some
point probably next month
in a video um but
that means that i'm gonna start playing
undertale
so it'll be my first time ever playing
that
feel free to join me on twitch the
counseling geeks twitch stream for that
tomorrow morning at 10 30 eastern
daylight time
but
the thing that i
really
want you to remember
is
that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council and i am just
the one who is privileged enough
to run the meetings
until next time council's adjourned
cavity